hello freak [ __ ] today is Wednesday
November 1st which means sober October
is over yeah I have saved my indulgences
to be here with you on Benjamin it's
such an honor
we're gonna drink some William Wolfe
bourbon it's perfect I'm not sure where
I got this I believe somebody gave it to
me
I hope it's not poison you gotta trust
the wolf I have a little this then we'll
spark up a doob party start cheers
alright thank grabs on October thank you
thank you I did not sober October I bet
you did you know what man that's a
[ __ ] that's a lost thing the ability
to go off yeah [ __ ] everybody's so
goddamn scared of repercussions of being
protested I mean everybody's being
hashtag called out I know and it's just
like it immobilizes people it's like
that's why I like season to this season
of stranger things you watching that
mm-hmm I like I like hopper like the cop
cuz he'll get pissed and be like sorry
it's cuz I just care so damn much you
could do that [ __ ] in the 80s yeah hey
oh sweet that is a marijuana in 31 days
oh that's nice
how's it feel it's good to be back feels
good I missed it I tell you what though
I enjoyed being sober not that I needed
to be sober not like I was a junkie with
the problem but it's nice to take a
reset I'm gonna do it every year
I'm gonna do sober October every year
there you heard it's good so give
yourselves up ladies and gentlemen
eleven months from now join on in maybe
you own them maybe you own Walt yeah
what do you think no I'm in man let's do
it I'll do sober october cuz this year i
I just hit my foot with an axe he's such
a you so are living in the boonies man I
don't know anybody in LA
that could tell me that where I wouldn't
call the police and say I don't know why
the [ __ ] you swinging an axe
well yeah cuz my brother does tree work
so I usually wear the good boots you
know right but I we fire we have fires
every every night and I really like like
a tinkering to make the fire good and
then I you know it's crack some beers
and then my family hangs out and then
they go inside and I crack more beers
and I had to chop some more wood and I
didn't put on the good boots and my axe
just careened off off it and hit me in
the foot so and I didn't I didn't have
time to get stitches so I just put a
maxi pad on it and it worked how big was
the cut it's pretty good [ __ ] they say
you should use whenever possible if you
can't get anywhere you use Krazy Glue
I've never tried that but I know a lot
of people who have and I know fighters
who have gotten cut in camp and just
used Krazy Glue crazy glued up the cut
and then made it to the fight didn't let
anybody know that they had a
pre-existing injury those guys are hard
as nails there's a lot of them that
they'll go into the Octagon with some
crazy [ __ ] what is this Philippe what
happened to him
flea plays doctor with superglue Wow
most people cut themselves ballet head
to the emergency room but when Red Hot
Chili Peppers bassist flea cut his thumb
open aggressively strumming his guitar
during a show he didn't have time for
surgery so keeping a crafty picked up
bottle superglue sealed the cut like any
good shirtless rock star would hmm yeah
I would do that in a heartbeat
like like cuts are like wounds I'm all
about just like doing [ __ ] like that
it's like broken bones yeah that's when
I know I gotta set it or so yeah that
seems like a flee move he seems like a
psycho yeah he pulled it out of his sock
oh yeah I remember they did an article
once he was talking about is how
important is pre-performance shits are
and I was like yeah they are important
but why is everybody why are we ashamed
of bowel movements why are we ashamed of
potty I don't know if we should be
honored to get rid of toxins Jamie and I
be talking about it openly because
you've got some new bathrooms for the
studio that have those Japanese toilets
that shoot hot water up your butt oh
yeah and they're warm so you sit in the
toilet it's heated like right away it's
like a warm
putting like come and come in and [ __ ]
come in and just release relax those
bowels and let it go let it go it's
awesome man I'm real meat and potatoes
with my shits I just get in I get out
but you know if there's another level to
it like what you're describing I want in
[Applause]
[Music]